botta
[Applauso]
[Musica]
mio libro storie paurose a scuola di
misteri e ora disponibile in libreria e
online metti alla prova il tuo coraggio
leggilo e accumula tutti i punti della
challenge nel libro basta oggi il
nuovissimo gioco paurose appena uscito
questo nuovo gioco che si chiama scappa
dalla casa di mister crisi che sarebbe
un personaggio che vedeva che gira la
testa numero gioco pauroso sapete che
noi amiamo i giochi paura temiamo anche
le cose paurose infatti anche il libro
storie paurose ce l'avete lo avete preso
scrivetelo nei commenti
e ora mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn e iniziamo subito questa nuovissima
e scopro difficoltà normale o difficile
chiudiamo con non fare perché altrimenti
moriamo
chi è questo questa è la casa di mister
prezzi vedi
wow è bellissimo la casa di mister
prezzi sembrano proprio una casa
infestata di fantasmi chi è questo non
lo andiamo a vedere un personale
giocatore allora avremo la loro casa in
più strada ad ore tra un po kitsch equa
questo è tipo il pupazzo di mister crisi
ma cosa succede se mi avvicino no non
posso neanche prenderlo peccato
roccarino di quando vi fa paura questo
mi sorpresi per ora non tanto trasporta
vitale entriamo vediamo
e così stanno iniziando le trappole in
questa casa infestata
ma bisogna saltare altre pa che succede
se cadi cadi nel baratro come lucky one
quando lo campeggiava
avete lasciato mi piace mi raccomando
lasciato mi piace questo e questo video
raggiunge 10 mila mi piace proveremo
altri giochi favolose assi consigliate
cieli pure nei commenti in questa volta
adesso
no guarda ci sono delle trappole questa
infetta quante volte si sfracella vitale
alcuni
testi ancora non si è sfracellato
che bello quello misto cognitivo 70
hanno preso anche
vediamo ma che scherzavo un pochettino
di paura piace cosa di fare una
sola ma sei tu
io ce l'ho fatta da evitato il principe
ce l'ho fatta come ho fatto a lavorarvi
per ora ma non è ancora finita l'ex game
room ok cos'altro si aspetta siamo qui
che cosa c'è bisogna rompere
sto facendo questi rumori strani o no a
quel pavimento e business
spesso a sinistra e l'afa e la in verde
nou dove sta esaltando to mattino metaj
saltato serbo eccoli aspettare un
aspetto niente io non è possibile che
evitare non sia ancora sfracellato che
fanno successo è diventato troppo bravo
prendiamo esternando è quello di far non
l'avevo vista sono nostra un pulsante
promuoverlo è non riesco primo pre
vogliono proprio io ok ci sono riusciti
a una centrale dove ci porterà
dove si può muovere speriamo non ci
porti da mister prezzi
vediamo vediamo
quarta punto si va in alto
ecco quasi ragnatele che è
bellissimo ma per fare di tre ad
halloween che si strutturino quello è un
giocatore che è rimasto questo
[Risate]
evitare rotte anche aspro celato non è
possibile
[Musica]
kim è appreso non e giusto di bill e
quindi bisogna correre forse qui per non
farci prendere lui esce da qualche parte
forse c'è qualche buco quale i muri che
gli usa dove dove dei no sono così
riusciti
anche a me ha preso alla fine no vabbè
che ansia adesso mi fiore latte deve
andare veloce tema pretese ma no perché
mi prende non riesco a capire perché
perché velocissimo fatto dai vita da qui
forse la fate tutto il tifo verbicaro ci
provo a cipro cirò
corretto parlare
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
così faccio è noto si è sfracellato
direttamente di larve
attento mister crisi lì e lì davanti a
noi non lo vedi
no
ma è immobile sono forze che io non lo
vedo
bene mica strumenti mi sfracello sempre
in queste griglie di laser sono
difficilissime intenzione non sono si
faceva con una volta non due tre forse
quattro boom allora voi avete tenuto
conto come mai
scomparso porto vítor cristi che
comparirà da perché parliamo adesso
allora qui c'è altri laser atteggerà
questi si muovono però niente tempo
in tempo ha detto quest'anno sfracellata
anch'io a proposito di cose e paurose
volevo ringraziarvi tantissimo perché
signori tantissime avete già preso il
mio nuovissimo libro storie paurose mi
avete mandato tantissime foto su mi
avete scritto tantissimi messaggi che mi
sta piacendo tantissimo loro alcuni
hanno già finito di lei
provinati mille ne siamo felicissimi che
il libro vi piaccia così tanto anzi
scriveteci nei commenti
qual è la nostra storia preferita la
vostra creatura preferita scrivetecelo
nei commenti se non avete ancora preso
andate a prenderlo e racconti
e riuscito a passare io e tu occorre
stai lì astro dell'arti
perché io provo a passare sotto ai laser
contro deve passare da sopra ok allora
abbia notiamo dai dai dai e via
fratta entriamo qui dai
non mi fa bisogna premere ok in
fallimento no
no no
che sì bastano gli scalini quindi
bisogna andare golosissimi ce n'è uno
alla volta allora facciamo mettere prima
loro via via
torre valutino
se ne basta
e riproviamo invece l'ho fatto non ci
credono affatto evitare possa partire
anche io dai
[Musica]
ciò va beh come fatto è difficile
bisogna cosa velocemente aiuto che ampia
sorriso e mary portatemi fortuna
non è possibile
aiuto quanto manca ancora se vi un altro
un altro solo un altro va in prova sei
molto bravo non ci credo non vi sulla
scala mi troverai alla fine della
scalata questa è una porta aspetta c'è
bisogno di una chiave per aprire vorrei
dire a qui a prenderla che se levo le
scale sono qui farò qui tale mi ha
superato
credo porta attenzione cosa c'è qui una
radio
guarda
ma è un dato che i fantasmi che tocca a
saltare su queste cose non so perché ma
io ti vedo che thai volando beh sì io ho
questi poteri volanti deve essere un bug
del gioco
qui c'è minimi mister crisi no solo caso
tra i master è un toni che ti
sfracellano
dove sei finito perché non è detto
perché tutti svolgerli allora andiamo
qui dove c'è questa francia e vitale
siamo scambiati i ruoli ora sono io che
mi sono state rivolte
o non ti dico che cosa ho trovato qui
rumore di un carillon molto inquietante
ecco mi sorprese la sopra è già scritto
uscita uscite uscita neri sono
sfracellato freccia eliseo fatto
salvando vino predice che quale uscita
nati i quali quattro tubi per credibili
a noi solo un poster per la ortona non è
lui attenta qui a bisogna saltare veloce
dei pezzi
è solo quelli che cadono aiuto non
cadono però io non lo so come si fa qui
forse diventa
papà io mi sono sfogato così quindi
forse non dobbiamo andare di là
proviamo a salire fa vediamo ma che li
dobbiamo trovare la chiave vediamo se
c'è qualcosa quando c'è un'altra porta
però vediamo da tivoli la chiave che può
ma maggio e la chiave magari questa
squadra non sono riuscito a prenderla
quella a questo è il carillon
ok riproviamo questa volta riusciremo a
portare più prodigo amano questo posto è
finto
è riuscita ha bisogno
bisogna bisogna che aspettare e
aspettare che si avvicini l'altra
piattaforma bravo che sei riuscito a
capirlo attento devi aspettare ma capita
sono arrivato alla fine
via
ok ora mettiamo che non porti di la
9 dal fratellino l'altro l'altro ok a
bisogna scegliere quella giusta
ok allora questa no ma che ora tutti e
due non è possibile ma quella è la
strada giusta
noi proviamo a destra per me è caduto
quindi forse cambia così
proviamo questo adesso
si sono fatta 3
questo è l'ultimo sarà questo dai
passava a fargli
noi dobbiamo allora
aiuto cosa che non cesso mi appresto
io mister credimi ha sgranocchiato anche
mister presi non mi prenderei questa
volta ma noi due
vediamo la luce questa moto ha comunque
lavorato
dobbiamo trovare un'altra strada deve
esserci un'altra strada altrimenti
d'acqua non riusciamo a portare allora
allora proviamo a vedere se c'è un'altra
strada mi aspettavo mentro aspetto c'era
una scritta c'è scritto non muoverti
visto davvero no non l'ho visto nel muro
c'è scritto non muove a farci forse
bisogna rimanere immobili quando il
rosso bisogna rimanere immobili che devo
andare
ok ok ok bravi abbiamo capito l'enigma
forse ancora non sappiamo se la strada
diventa rosso
fermo adesso verde
vedi c'è scritto lì juno
muro proprio così
aiuto piante
è fatto spaventare
ok calma e concentrazione
forse vitale ci sta riuscendo no alla
vita mi ha preso ok ho un'idea il mio
piano d'azione quest fermarsi prima di
vivere paratissima di diventare ok io mi
fermo già
ok via via via fermi e adesso ve lo devo
andare
ok funziona
giallo perché io sono passato già bravo
beato te
che ami
pista piccoli pacchetto
ce l'ho fatta a
taiz
aiuto
ha detto ti mancava poco essere quasi
devi salire poi subito ne andare da sola
ok libertà
ma di sanità adesso ok ok adesso giallo
vedendo passare bene
è stato difficile questo stage
un lievito milano sto esplorando e sopra
tutti questi forziere no
ho sentito il rumore di qualcuno che si
è sfracellato
wow cosa c'è qua dentro
abbiamo forse scoprire il forziere
giusto non aprire la scatola sbagliata
prova ora possiamo aprire con tutte
quelle porte proviamo l'hai trovato qui
dopo si è sempre diverso allora devi
provare gli altri e torna prima parte
iniziale
ok ho preso le chiavi ok adesso qual era
la porta e poi dovrebbero portare
dobbiamo aprire questo all'uscita ci sei
ci sono ci sono sono quindi domenica
apriamo l'uscita di c
era una donna ministro che non è finita
qua e c'è un raise ora ricomparirà
sicuramente ricomparirà mister presi
da che sta salendo in aria
allora vediamo questo ci porterà allo
stage finale come star questi potrebbe
spuntare fuori all'improvviso mi
sorpresi stai molto attento sì c'è
problema sono diventato bravissimo ormai
si sentirà musichetta quando si sente il
cariolo vuol dire che lui è vicino
aspetta aspetta aspetta che c'è no no mi
stavo cercando di capire come saltare su
youtube attento che qui ci sono delle
scorie la testa è salvata guarda come
faccio io ritengo accennato ci sono dei
teschi scheletri e topi
si è rotta va dal tubo su caduto setose
non ha beni sbrigarti io sto soltanto in
rete dai topi praticamente il tubero e
arrugginita si no quando
saliamo questo vediamo
quando si è visto il credito il lancio
guarda guarda che cosa dobbiamo fare
dobbiamo dobbiamo camminare dobbiamo
scappare cosa dobbiamo fare
vai tu davanti
la prima sto cercando di capire dobbiamo
andare vedi fuori dal cancello si
esistono delle cose luminose al vedete
la giudice non può prendere il badge
laggiù credo ok proviamo a scappare
allora
ce n'è più di uno tempo no è
possibile dove l'uscita
corridori come se
fossero state passa un po
non ci dirò io ce l'ho fatto di vista
stare sopra l'albero sopra la forza
se così fosse il caso moro daihatsu
cubitale laggiù facciamo tutti il tifo
per vitale e percorrendo quindi bruga
dai viveri 4 nota è
appreso scritto quasi tascapane crisi
mi piacciono meno insomma fa 4 casilina
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video su quella che preferite